المواد الغذائيه وبالاخص الدقيق هو احد
اوجه معاناه المواطنين اليوميه هنا في
قطاع غزه في ظل اشتداد الحرب والحصار
وايضا منع الاحتلال دخول اي مساعدات حتى
هذه اللحظه هنا الى شمال قطاع غزه هناك
صعوبه في الحصول على الدقيق وايضا هناك
غلاء في الاسعار بسبب ندره الدقيق وعدم
توفره نهائيا هنا في الاسواق في شمال غزه
الشمال معدوم بالنسبه للطحين لمواد التم
معدومين متوفر عننا حلويات
حاجه بنسلي الاولاد بحاجه نص كافيه بليدن
بحلو مصاص بنصبر اولادنا على الرز اما
طحين والله صعب جدا حتى القمح يعني بندور
عليه نطحنه يدوي على ايدينا بطحنه على
الايد رجعنا على ايام الزمان يعني صحيح
على الايد بنعمله اليوم ممكن تلاقي طحين
في السوق بس 700 شكل يعني 200
دولار انا اللي بحكي معاك يعني انا يعني
عندي ارب اربع مخابز في شمال غزه ولا
استطيع الحصول على كيلو من الدقيق يعني
امور بالنسبه للطحين صعبه صعبه جدا للغايه
اكثر من شهر تقريبا انا اكثر من شهر
واسرتي لا استطيع يعني الحصول على كيلو
واحد من الطحين وان توفر فاسم باهظه جدا
اضعاف مضاعفه يعني الكيس اللي كان يباع ب
35 شيكل ال بنتكلم فيه عن 700 و800 شيكل
حتى العائلات التي استطاعت توفير كميات
محدوده من الدقيق تعاني ايضا في خبزه احنا
مش ملاقي مكان اخبز فيه الا المكان هذا
والطحين طحين المره يعني بلاقي طحين على
صعوبه يعني ك الطحين او نص نص بوفر على 50
شيكل او كمان 55 شيكل صعب جدا جدا جدا
يعني انا والله العظيم والله العظيم بش
يعني احلف كمان يعني شهرين ما طتش اولادي
خبز لسه هي اول مره لسه اخبز مش عندي خبز
تماما يعني بالعافيه بنلاقي اللقمه نروح
نطعم الصغار احنا من مره فيش وين وين لما
نلاقي الخبز والمكان هذا رحت نقيته عشان
اجي اخبز فيه فش مكان فيشي لا اكل ولا شرب
ولا ميه ولا غذاء ولا ولا شي ولا شيء
الدول شايفه وساكته يتها كمان تقف معانا
وتحط ايديها معان يا
ريت واكثر من هيك ما فيش حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل على كل واحد ظالم على كل واحد
شايفنا
وساكت هنا في شمال غزه كما باقي مناطق
القطاع لا يتوفر اي مقومات اساسيه
للاستمرار في الحياه وما زال الاحتلال
يمنع دخول المساعدات والمعاناه ما زالت
تتفاقم يوما بعد يوم منذ شهور انس الشريف
الجزيره شمال
غزه